ciao tour della tensione in the stories
oggi challenge speciale come avrete già
capito finalmente acquisite
vedremo allora cominciamo con la nave
sulla pizza per favore la cassazione
invece la state chiedendo da tantissimo
tempo e la challenger più richiesta in
assoluto sul canale e infatti questo è
uno speciale stree 100mila iscritti per
ingrandendolo pirlo troppo video più
bella di youtube siamo tantissimi
continuiamo a crescere tantissimo e
velocissimamente non ci posso credere
sono troppo felice siete speciali triste
mettete i migliori e quindi questo è il
nostro speciale
smettila speciale ovviamente evitare
bellissimo di fare le spalle secoli cibo
come funziona sicuramente 0 st prete noi
andiamo a girare la ruota e qualsiasi
ingrediente ci capiti dobbiamo
aggiungerlo la pizza anche quelli tifosi
poi alla fine dovremo mangiarla lasciate
un bel live se volete vedere altre sale
lì se questo video aggiunge 10 mila rai
sat roma frenata anche charles quindi
come questa ster of honey pacchetto
pancakes con i magistrati quindi mi
raccomando lasciate un bel like e ora
siete pronti mettetevi comodi fate fine
pop corn video a tutto schermo
patetico per me
iniziamo subito
[Musica]
ma niente di niente
primo turno stop gambe
aiutiamo dalla pista verso votato né il
primo né niente schifoso mi doveva
capitare a tutti la vendita il mandato
di buon primo ingrediente alla fine si
fa la pizza con l'ananas quindi magari
anche quella mela banana sembrano fatti
di mozzarella mini petteni mozzarella
litio però visto lontano può sembrare
una pizza con le fette di mozzarella o
che il mio primo strappo è fatto
[Musica]
tavano dure si sky
peccato che la pizza e la barbie invece
le sue dolci bomber denuncino avete un
po di peperoncino chissà come sarà bella
il calco della bit cantina troppi beh
qui abbiamo il peperoncino in sé ma non
solo piccante fotocamera difficile
questi si facciamo uno scambio
guardate la review panchina è la fitta
ma la mia volontà di campo e la forma si
chiama che trovi campo
[Musica]
il maglie banana con una combinazione
perfetta
ecco qua il nostro vaglio ok più già
messo un tacco è occupata di travaglio
gestivano varano addio molto punta
tantissimo primo di qualcosa di buono
[Musica]
per il peperoncino
iamm di cereali armiere
[Applauso]
brunetta ma per il vaticano di per terra
perfetti la sede sia il rabbino cev e
gino una festa ronci e per funzionalità
traduzioni tocca a me se va bene da
salvare e lo stesso dolce una marmellata
[Musica]
magari scopriamo con questo tipo di
fitta e super buona sì certo come lo è
[Musica]
obiettivo interruzioni nuovamente
sappiamo peroncino brutta lingua ok
altro peperoncino
non bastava di 20 mesi ma che metti
menti quello che si è poi dovuto capire
infatti questa brutta è proprio la sua
[Musica]
canzone
allora di mettere colorate che bisogna
scegliere occhi chiusi darà un bel tocco
di colore in questa pizza per dire
questa porta lasciata channel ecco qua e
coloranti abbiamo il roster perdere dato
più gli occhi già sappiamo qual è il
peggiore
allora devo fare sempre quello che
voglio io lasciando un altro quindi io
odio questo quindi citato questo il
verdetto sembra di phuket e dolce questo
colore di niente lezioni che devo fare
una fetta di pizza nuovamente la banana
questo che mi ha dato la vita diventerà
una bella anni e marmellata vittima
[Musica]
diamo a chi perde ronzino colorante
rosso e dopo aver assaggiato questa
pizza tante volte non proprio sentir
parlare di pizza per un anno ma chi ci
crede e lo mangerei utilizzo nonché a
colazione
www passaggio ma dobbiamo assaggiarla
deve associare enel che non rispettava
tutte le stia ora che alla fine ottiene
intima allora devo tagliare un po di
peperoncino
no ma va benissimo
va beh finché sentito il sapore della
parete lavora mi andava bene ma poi di
vaio deliziosa che di certo non è banale
di generali gli odori punti proprio
mentre capitare line ha tra l'altro nov
aldo drudi no guarda il proprio bene
purtroppo di aria hai detto che avresti
malgrado tutta tutta travaglia tutto no
così dario piano che ti becchi l'anno il
tuo preferito non sentire profumo di
aglio banana delizioso ok dopo a me
[Musica]
vvvvvv il tuo preferito
non puoi mangiare mi capita però
capitola
guardando ai fondi delle fette più
grosse che so queste finte 20 è convinto
che la bellissima troverò davvero
cameron e peperoncino padana
[Musica]
ok ragazzi ora siamo entrati nell'ultimo
round quindi a reagire a vitale per
l'ultima volta e poi però io per
l'ultima volta perché beh speriamo un
bell'assaggio solo un bello dello stop
prima quando la sterlina
[Musica]
si no ma non cazzo nell'altra città
bellissima nonno mio giocatore che
vorrei tanto ne potete sentire perché
c'è un mix di aiutare la mamma vittoria
che si arrabbierà tantissimo e raccolta
di cover che dice perché la vecchia la
soprano la mangi la mattina andrà anche
la mattina abbiamo ritrovate e l'ultimo
round
ti prego premi oddio la prima mezz'ora
parliamone grado per tutte e due in
irlanda
quasi tutti mangiano la pizza con
l'ananas noi non abbiamo mai capito il
perché e chi fa creare questa cosa tutti
gli italiani che vivono in irlanda di
famoso strada ora sentito che anche in
italia sono persone quando ero abituato
ma l'anas fa sapere se voi mangiate la
beta condanna che è soprattutto perché
non abbiamo mai provato magari
buonissima bello scoprirò adesso ha una
bella fetta del quoziente oggi ma sono
due obiettivi o miste rata non vado di
frutta che però non hanno i miei cani
che ne pensate pare la più bella la mia
di natale ma questi cosa effettivamente
molto in questa doppietta john dati
colori e 103 gusto
ora andiamo a tagliarla una marmellata e
cereali
espongo verificare se no poi dopo un
buon pranzo oggi prendiamo così aspetta
da me nazione che si incrociano il
colorante i cereali
così appena ma di funghi e la marmellata
tutto che assaggia pure perché io sono
uno sprone alla volta tantissimo a stime
non ho promesso che strano un sapore
come granaio che sono la marmellata ma
sentito primo tutto dolce voi amaro come
vediamo aggiungere tutto con buone
l'ultimo cosa piccante salato acido c'è
di tutto quindi non ti piace per niente
io preferire un bel piatto di pasta
impresa di vedere come pasta pizza
[Musica]
il peperone crudo la no stop per oncino
paranà marmellata e poi c'era
qualcos'altro ha dato prova ecco il
peperone farmi controllare dove sta bene
acqua andata vota giorni che la corea
secondo me ho vinto io almeno sia
piaciuto non manca un'ora buona parte
con il dio dov'è nuovo grazie grazie
adesso gioco la mia che abbiamo
assaggiato la mia sarà un modo vestito
di quella torta che abbiamo fatto vede
l'attraversamento
cetrini un pochino commentiamo questa
questa designer sono difficili da
recuperare
mamma mia terribile potessi fare secondo
voi qual è la più schifosa quella mia o
quella di vitale sapere tutto nei
commenti
lasciateci nei commenti il 30 del
momento che vi è divertito di più perché
noi ci divertiamo sempre a cliccare di
testa per richiedere l'essere più
divertenti e non mi raccomando lasciate
un bel live su questo video e ora vi
lasciamo fa 4 quadratini 4 catherine cui
potete cliccare le nostre aree challenge
i nostri video divertenti cliccate su
quello che preferite e buona visione